vous savez, les lutteurs professionnels sont
des artistes
mais ils sont fous et j'ai grandi dans un
monde de
grands hommes fous du divertissement
qui m'ont appris très tôt la valeur de la
discipline et de la main d'acier
[Musique]
quand j'avais 15 ans et j'en ai
parlé plus tôt  j'ai été expulsé nous avons été
expulsés de notre appartement d'une chambre
à Honolulu Hawaii nous avons été forcés de
quitter l'île
et nous y sommes aujourd'hui j'ai entendu une citation
quand j'avais euh quand j'avais 15 ans
et moi et je pensais que si jamais j'y serais
un jour,
j'aimerais pouvoir vivre cette citation
et j'ai pensé que c'était le
moment idéal pour vous livrer cette citation
parce que cela signifie tellement pour moi ici,
dans mon mana, dans mon esprit, ce qui est
sympa  être important mais c'est plus
important d'être gentil
[Musique]
je viens de cette famille de lutte folle, parfois
dysfonctionnelle,
mon père, ma grand-mère et mon
grand-père, mes
oncles, mes cousins, vous l'appelez, je jouais pour
les Stampeders de Calgary,
nous jouions contre les Lions de la Colombie-Britannique, j'étais tellement
excité
deux jours plus tard, j'ai été éliminé c'est un rêve
brisé renvoyé à la maison avec sept dollars en
poche c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
décidé que
j'en avais fini de jouer au football,
mon tout premier match à la WWE était
à l'un de leurs plus gros pay-per-  vues de
l'année appelées série de survivants
dans l'arène la plus célèbre
du monde Madison Square Garden où
mon grand-père a lutté dans les années 70 pour le
père de Vince Mcmahon
mon père a lutté pour Vince Mcmahon dans les
années 80 et ici je suis arrivé en 1996.
c'est juste une question  d'avoir une
carrière diversifiée et de vouloir travailler dans autant de
genres différents que possible
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
je suis un gars chanceux ce sont toutes les filles c'est très
spécial
donne-moi plus d'œstrogènes
[Musique]
je respecte notre processus politique je  et je
ne me fais pas d'illusions sur le fait
que c'est facile peut-être 20 24 peut-être 20 28
je ne sais pas